[Música]
nuevo luego que economía en directo
de france24 ya está conmigo
nuevamente en el estudio luis méndez
zúrich louis vamos a hablar de argentina
comenzamos este bloque económico en
nuestra región porque el gobierno busca
así controlar la alta inflación en el
país la podrá controlar eso se espera
porque para ello este lunes el gobierno
encabezado por el ministro de desarrollo
productivo matías kulfas debe sostener
un encuentro con representantes del
sector empresarial de esa nación para
recordar que el pasado mes de febrero la
inflación alcanzó en la nación 4 puntos
7 puntos porcentuales por ello las
autoridades buscan discutir un paquete
de medidas que permitan una reducción de
precios especialmente en el rubro de
alimentos en el que se presentó la mayor
variación al alza durante el segundo mes
del año en esta reunión se espera que
también participa el titular de la
secretaría de comercio exterior roberto
feletti quien en el pasado impulsó el
establecimiento del plan precios
congelados para controlar estos aumentos
y ahora si pasamos al conflicto entre
rusia y ucrania por que la unión europea
analiza una quinta ronda de sanciones
contra moscú y en estas acciones el
bloque de los 27 se estaría contemplando
un posible embargo al petróleo ruso algo
que sólo lo han establecido hasta el
momento eeuu y el reino unido- la
noticia que fue dada a conocer previo al
comienzo del encuentro en bruselas a
convocó o provocó un alza de precios en
el barril de petróleo este se cotizó en
los futuro del brent en 111 punto 33
dólares por barril al tiempo que el west
texas se ubicó en 108 puntos 3 dólares
por barril en embargo al petróleo ruso
como parte de las sanciones por la
invasión a ucrania han estado sobre la
mesa en las diversas discusiones pero
han tenido posición de alemania de
acuerdo con medios europeos pero
escuchemos qué fue lo que dijo el
ministro de relaciones exteriores
virtual
yo creo que es inevitable comenzar a
hablar sobre el sector energético y
definitivamente podemos hablar sobre el
petróleo porque es el mayor ingreso para
el presupuesto ruso y también es
fácilmente reemplazable debido a nuestra
infraestructura y los múltiples
suministros existentes
pero moscú ha respondido a la
posibilidad del embargo por parte de la
unión europea y sobre ello dmitri peskov
el portavoz del gobierno ruso informó
que ese tema es muy complicado porque
tal embargo afectaría el mercado mundial
de petróleo y en general afectará a los
balances energéticos en la unión europea
por otro lado el viceprimer ministro
alexander novak citado por la agencia
rusa interfax señaló que la negativa de
eeuu y reino unido- de comprar petróleo
ruso generaría un impacto pequeño en las
compras de esa nación puesto que lo que
quieren estos países son cantidades
pequeñas pero no se ha referido al
impacto que podría tener una medida
similar por parte de la unión europea
ahora lo empezamos a hablar de áfrica
porque egipto anunció un paquete de
ayuda económica
y esté de acuerdo con la agencia de
noticias reuters está orientado a
aliviar el impacto de la situación
económica global dentro de la población
de ese país este tendría un valor de 130
mil millones de libras egipcias es decir
poco más de 7 mil 123 millones de
dólares y contempla entre otras cosas
exenciones de impuestos y ajustes
salariales por otro lado autoridades de
ese país informaron que el fondo de
riqueza soberana creado en 2019 para
atraer inversiones extranjeras consiguió
más de 2 mil millones de dólares en
inversiones las cuales serán anunciadas
en el futuro y quienes trae como cifra
el día louis tiene que ver en este caso
con la apuesta de acciones por parte de
la empresa fabricante de yates ferretti
que fueron más de
83.5 millones de acciones las que
pondrán a la venta en su salida a la
bolsa en hong kong gracias entonces por
toda la información louis nos vemos
mañana con más economía nos vamos
directo a esa pareja salís a natalia